What's a well-meaning decision by one person
is outright censorship to the next.
What we now know is that this account, Texas Lone Star,
was part of a wider Russian disinformation campaign,
one that has since been taken down.
Would that change your view?
It would mine,
because now it's a case of a coordinated campaign
to sow discord.
And for those of you who'd like to think
that artificial intelligence will solve all of our problems,
I think we can agree that we're a long way away
from AI that's able to make sense of posts like this.
So I'd like to explain three interlocking issues
that make this so complex
and then think about some ways we can consider these challenges.
First, we just don't have a rational relationship to information,
we have an emotional one.
It's just not true that more facts will make everything OK,
because the algorithms that determine what content we see,
well, they're designed to reward our emotional responses.
And when we're fearful,
oversimplified narratives, conspiratorial explanations
and language that demonizes others is far more effective.
And besides, many of these companies,
their business model is attached to attention,
which means these algorithms will always be skewed towards emotion.
Second, most of the speech I'm talking about here is legal.
It would be a different matter
if I was talking about child sexual abuse imagery
or content that incites violence.
It can be perfectly legal to post an outright lie.
But people keep talking about taking down "problematic" or "harmful" content,
but with no clear definition of what they mean by that,
including Mark Zuckerberg,
who recently called for global regulation to moderate speech.
And my concern is that we're seeing governments
right around the world
rolling out hasty policy decisions
that might actually trigger much more serious consequences
when it comes to our speech.
And even if we could decide which speech to take up or take down,
we've never had so much speech.
Every second, millions of pieces of content
are uploaded by people right around the world
in different languages,
drawing on thousands of different cultural contexts.
We've simply never had effective mechanisms
to moderate speech at this scale,
whether powered by humans or by technology.
And third, these companies -- Google, Twitter, Facebook, WhatsApp --
they're part of a wider information ecosystem.
We like to lay all the blame at their feet, but the truth is,
the mass media and elected officials can also play an equal role
in amplifying rumors and conspiracies when they want to.
As can we, when we mindlessly forward divisive or misleading content
without trying.
We're adding to the pollution.
I know we're all looking for an easy fix.
But there just isn't one.
Any solution will have to be rolled out at a massive scale, internet scale,
and yes, the platforms, they're used to operating at that level.
But can and should we allow them to fix these problems?
They're certainly trying.
But most of us would agree that, actually, we don't want global corporations
to be the guardians of truth and fairness online.
And I also think the platforms would agree with that.
And at the moment, they're marking their own homework.
They like to tell us
that the interventions they're rolling out are working,
but because they write their own transparency reports,
there's no way for us to independently verify what's actually happening.
(Applause)
And let's also be clear that most of the changes we see
only happen after journalists undertake an investigation
and find evidence of bias
or content that breaks their community guidelines.
So yes, these companies have to play a really important role in this process,
but they can't control it.
So what about governments?
Many people believe that global regulation is our last hope
in terms of cleaning up our information ecosystem.
But what I see are lawmakers who are struggling to keep up to date
with the rapid changes in technology.
And worse, they're working in the dark,
because they don't have access to data
to understand what's happening on these platforms.
And anyway, which governments would we trust to do this?
We need a global response, not a national one.
So the missing link is us.
It's those people who use these technologies every day.
Can we design a new infrastructure to support quality information?
Well, I believe we can,
and I've got a few ideas about what we might be able to actually do.
So firstly, if we're serious about bringing the public into this,
can we take some inspiration from Wikipedia?
They've shown us what's possible.
Yes, it's not perfect,
but they've demonstrated that with the right structures,
with a global outlook and lots and lots of transparency,
you can build something that will earn the trust of most people.
Because we have to find a way to tap into the collective wisdom
and experience of all users.
This is particularly the case for women, people of color
and underrepresented groups.
Because guess what?
They are experts when it comes to hate and disinformation,
because they have been the targets of these campaigns for so long.
And over the years, they've been raising flags,
and they haven't been listened to.
This has got to change.
So could we build a Wikipedia for trust?
Could we find a way that users can actually provide insights?
They could offer insights around difficult content-moderation decisions.
They could provide feedback
when platforms decide they want to roll out new changes.
Second, people's experiences with the information is personalized.
My Facebook news feed is very different to yours.
Your YouTube recommendations are very different to mine.
That makes it impossible for us to actually examine
what information people are seeing.
So could we imagine
developing some kind of centralized open repository for anonymized data,
with privacy and ethical concerns built in?
Because imagine what we would learn
if we built out a global network of concerned citizens
who wanted to donate their social data to science.
Because we actually know very little
about the long-term consequences of hate and disinformation
on people's attitudes and behaviors.
And what we do know,
most of that has been carried out in the US,
despite the fact that this is a global problem.
We need to work on that, too.
And third,
can we find a way to connect the dots?
No one sector, let alone nonprofit, start-up or government,
is going to solve this.
But there are very smart people right around the world
working on these challenges,
from newsrooms, civil society, academia, activist groups.
And you can see some of them here.
Some are building out indicators of content credibility.
Others are fact-checking,
so that false claims, videos and images can be down-ranked by the platforms.
A nonprofit I helped to found, First Draft,
is working with normally competitive newsrooms around the world
to help them build out investigative, collaborative programs.
And Danny Hillis, a software architect,
is designing a new system called The Underlay,
which will be a record of all public statements of fact
connected to their sources,
so that people and algorithms can better judge what is credible.
And educators around the world are testing different techniques
for finding ways to make people critical of the content they consume.
All of these efforts are wonderful, but they're working in silos,
and many of them are woefully underfunded.
There are also hundreds of very smart people
working inside these companies,
but again, these efforts can feel disjointed,
because they're actually developing different solutions to the same problems.
How can we find a way to bring people together
in one physical location for days or weeks at a time,
so they can actually tackle these problems together
but from their different perspectives?
So can we do this?
Can we build out a coordinated, ambitious response,
one that matches the scale and the complexity of the problem?
I really think we can.
Together, let's rebuild our information commons.
Thank you.
(Applause)